okay let's let's take her last a last
quick reflection from each of you and i
really do mean fairly quick uh ladies
and gentlemen just a quick reflection on
whether we're richer in 10 years time on
your expectation and if so how come well
i'm obviously not going to answer that
right because i'm uh
what i would the question that intrigued
me was the one about the morality
of economics because in in america
anyways the the uh
this this question is often framed not
as an economics question but as a kind
of and by the way it's it's we really
are living in the age of economists
right i mean look at this panel and
if we'd done this five years ago we
would have been talking about the
culture wars right and like the theory
of evolution and something like that and
in america we have these economic
debates but we debate them as a form of
culture war
okay and there's there's a a large
school of thought in american politics
that insists we need to let
the economy fail to try to prop it up in
any way is immoral it's time for our
day of judgment as i think it's senator
rand paul
from kentucky likes to say it's time for
our day of judgment to run you know to
do some kind of deficit spending program
is a is some is is you know flouting the
will of the almighty
and uh there's this you know very
moralistic view of what needs to happen
to us and what needs to happen to us is
that we need to get spanked we've been
bad we've lived beyond our means for too
long and now it's time for us to be
punished thomas thank you very much
diane
i think the upstairs questioners were
absolutely right that in the
long run it's innovation and
productivity that make us richer and
there's lots of that out there still and
it's not new ipods but it's it's
graphene and other smart materials and
it's uh biotechnology and it's
agricultural productivity and it's also
all the innovations that seem really old
me but make a difference to your life
like
tights that don't get wrinkled and socks
that don't smell and different flavored
breakfast cereals and all of that stuff
so i don't know ten years is the right
time horizon but we will get there but
fdr made a speech when he said you judge
your society by how well it does by the
poorest members not how much more it
gives to the richest ones and that's the
one we haven't cracked yet
so martin i think all the government
efforts should be on uh
generating productive
productive
uh activities which employ people
unemployment is the big enemy and you do
that by simplifying uh and the
restrictions on employing young people
in business particularly small
businesses which are ridiculously
onerous right now
by
adjusting the planning system to make it
much easier to get planning permission
for
industries which are going to employ
people by helping the infrastructure
doing the infrastructure making
transportation easier and by reducing
tax on small and medium-sized businesses
well um i agree uh very much uh with
diane i think we will be uh richer in 10
15 years time i think the key to where
the growth will come from is going to be
the 5 billion new uh consumers
increasingly not just producers that are
that are
coming becoming part of the world
economy they're only one-tenth to
one-fifth as rich as we are they're
going to consume more and more and of
course that will put a lot of strain on
the world's resources but it will they
will be consuming to large extent
products but also crucially services
that we provide uh and
so so it will be catering to the world
but in doing that we've got to think
about what it is that we can provide for
the rest of the world and here i think
there is a very controversial issue the
thing that we in britain have so far
over the last not just hundred years but
over the last two or three hundred years
been particularly good at providing for
the rest of the world is finance and it
is trade and it is these uh business
services so and i think that will
continue to be britain's most important
area of compassion competitive advantage
and the point i would make is that even
if finance is a zero-sum game where
we're just shuffling pieces of paper
with no productive output
if that's what the world rest of the
world wants us to do basically this is a
kind of parlor game which the rest of
the world wants us to play for it i
think we would be very foolish not to do
it and the last point i would make is
that it's easier to say that finance is
unproductive and even damaging but is it
actually more unproductive and damaging
than making fast cars
than making uh porsches which kill
people which pollute the environment and
which make a lot of very vulgar noise i
don't think so i would i would rather be
a banker than a shareholder and porsche
there may be some overlap between
i rather agree with anatol that we
should go on running the casino so long
as we don't allow british people to play
in it with our money
like
that's right
uh
on the growth question i would answer
that we the product i don't think we
will be richer in 10 years time and my
reasoning is that although i think the
innovation will continue in the ways and
in the areas that diane has described
i think our mess capacity to mess up our
political and financial institutions is
currently so great that we will not
actually enjoy a net benefit from that
process
and i think directly relevant to that i
would like to end by picking up the
morality issue once again
and saying that in my view not only
is morality not inconsistent with a
market economy it's actually
indispensable to making it work
bear stands at a sign over its trading
floor that said we make nothing but
money
and in the long run the result was it
wasn't very successful even in making
that
it should be a lesson there for all of
us stephen
um well
my prediction will be that our absolute
growth rates will be significantly lower
than they have been over the last 50 or
60 years which has been an extraordinary
period of rising wealth and rising
prosperity
our entitlements overall will have to be
cut back because we've assumed that we
have that continuous increase in
prosperity at that rate carrying on into
the future it will not happen
as far as global growth is concerned it
will come increasingly from parts of the
emerging world as it has been already
over the last 10 15 years when we're
beating ourselves up about the
disappointments in the uk and the u.s
extraordinary increases in living
standards in other parts of the world um
absolutely revolutionary
and and my final thought is um
to use an option we haven't discussed as
yet which is what i like to call the the
theological option uh which basically
involves praying for a strong recovery
there are lots of policymakers who
rediscovered god in recent times and i
hope that god exists thank you
and
my answer to evan's question is in 10
years time on a per capita basis um i
think britain
could be richer than what it is now
if and this is the engine of growth if
it
fakes it
and then
has real gains in productivity by
selling to china and india and this is
what i mean so without exception with
one ex with the exception of one country
in europe uh no recovery from recession
no growth has ever come from
uh being harder on your own domestic
economy it's always come from making
your currency cheaper selling more via
exports and that gives you artificial
competitiveness in the short term but
the key in a very very competitive world
economy is to fake it first and then to
make it real in the process to really
increase competitiveness and
productivity through innovation
rebalancing the economy incentivizing uh
value-added making sure britain doesn't
get relegated and by doing that then
britain is in a very good position to
continue to sell to the fastest growing
economies in the world and the emerging
middle class which is coming from china
and india and their potential is immense
even indonesia which is the smallest of
these big countries i'm talking about
its population today is what the united
states was in 1980 and the united states
power the world economy with that
population with just 200 or so million
people and china and india have over 2
billion together and i think that's the
future that's been the key to britain's
success being very global very
internationally oriented and that
provides the best hope or prayer for
growth in the short to the medium term
last word
last word to gideon and then we're out
of here i don't think i have anything
very inspirational to say i think that
the the world as a whole will definitely
be
more prosperous and richer in 10 years
time unfortunately i fear the exception
to that is europe because of the
enormous mess that we're going to have
to work out through getting the euro
crisis sorted out plus all the
demographic pressures but i think even
europe in 15 years time will be okay but
i think we've got a really rough decade
ahead
right
i'm not sure we cracked it but we had a
very interesting time along the way um
i'd love to buy you all dinner i'm
afraid i can't
i will for the gentleman who mentioned
my book up there otherwise it just
behooves me to say thank you to you for
your questions to intelligence squared
for organizing it apologies for
finishing a little bit late we had so
much to get in but above all to say
thank you very much to the pound
you